on the phone now Peter King perhaps my
favorite writer in the business read his
column each and every Monday morning
with a cup of coffee I guess Peter the
only thing I could ask for is if it came
in actual newspaper form so I could turn
the pages like you know some of the old
guys like me like to do hey Dan thanks
so much I mean I I when I was in high
school in Connecticut I used to my dad
used to go out and get the Boston Globe
every every weekend and and I remember
the way I got the whole idea and how
cool it would be to write a notes column
like this is from Peter Gammons in the
Boston Globe and I used to love Sunday
Boston Globe with Peter Gammons and will
McDonagh and Bob Ryan and and all those
guys you know later Jackie McMullen and
and and and it just it was the treat and
it sort of taught me this weird little
genre of writing way way way too long it
seemed too long a full open page in a in
a broadsheet newspaper in those days and
I've taken it to ridiculous lengths now
in an annoyingly ridiculous lengths but
but anyway it's kind of what I do well
what you did this week is you visited
with former Packers head coach Mike
McCarthy and my biggest takeaway there
is that he has started to study things
that maybe he didn't study as much in
the past when he comes back and he plans
on coming back to be the head coach of a
football team hopefully next year he
wants to have a 14 person football
technology department the reason this
struck me Peter is because there are
several teams around the NFL more than a
handful that don't have a technology
department period they don't have one
person that's in charge of analytics
they'll stick a scout or two to look at
a couple of analytics reports or the
next-gen numbers that they get you know
from the NFL and from their GPS tracking
devices but he's going an entirely
different direction
well I think been in the last four or
five years in fact one of the
interesting things that that McCarthy
has has done is he's looked at every
team in the NFL and tried as best he
could through you know true you know
team websites and team personnel
directories he's tried to figure out how
many people in every organization are
assigned to the study of the analytics
and sort of advanced statistics and
numbers and he he believes he spent some
time at pro Football Focus in the
offseason and he just believes there is
a lot of upside and the funny thing is
in the story I was I was telling him
that James Holt our the jeopardy
champion who won 2.7 million dollars he
demolished the field there I think for
32 shows last summer on Jeopardy
and I you know because McCarthy was
talking about the the kind of people he
wanted you know he wants outside the box
thinkers he wants people coming to him
and saying why do you do it this way
this way is better and and I told him
about Holzhauer and he said to me I want
to talk to him and so look the whole
tower wants to work in analytics in
baseball or football but I I just think
that McCarthy understands that if he's
going to get back into it and an owner
and a president a GM are going to
entrust your organization to him they
want to make sure that he's a modern guy
and open to a lot of the new things that
characterize football these days well
along with Marvin Lewis and Ron Rivera
they're going to be former NFL head
coaches and a lot of people's lists
Lincoln Reilly Matt rule of course you
have the assistants like Josh McDaniels
and Greg Roman maybe even wink
Martindale it's you talk about the
analytics department that some teams
have and some tea
don't have every team has a video
Department let's just bang this this
Patriots question out of way right now
did we learn anything by seeing that
video that the Jay Glazer and Fox
released over the weekend that we didn't
already know or that changes how the NFL
will hand down a punishment because I'm
assuming there has to be some sort of
punishment handed down oh there will be
I think you know mark masky wrote in The
Washington Post over the weekend that
it's unlikely to be Omega sanction it's
more likely to be either a you know a
lesser draft choice or a reduction you
know in where the draft choice is taken
along with you know significant fine
but look I thought I a manok what's
giving in to Jay Glazer he's he's a
pretty good detective and good for Jay
for for getting that so we could see it
and we could see exactly what it is the
NFL is looking at I think that is good
for the public but I don't really see
how it changes the the investigation by
the NFL instead of now 20 people seeing
this state maybe 10 million people will
see it but I don't really think that
materially changes the investigation the
Patriots are going to claim and have
claimed that this guy was doing what he
thought he should be doing to do a good
job to tell the story of their advanced
scout and you know he obviously did not
do that they're going to be some people
including several coaches in the NFL I
can tell you firsthand who are going to
say that's a bunch of BS
nothing happens there without Belichick
fingerprints all over it and I've said
to several of them a we haven't heard of
this for years
somebody just bringing a camera into a
press box and automatically just taping
the sidelines I mean this is this the
first time they've done it in years or
do they do it in some other nefarious
way that we don't
and why would they do it so that it was
observed by 250 people in a in a press
box at an NFL game it just it seems a
little bit weird quite honestly to think
that this is some organized clot on the
part of the Patriots I just think it's
an entirely different Department and I
think Bill Belichick is worried about
the game planning not the program that's
going to be featuring an advanced scout
and the video that they shoot for that I
just it's just I don't know I like to
believe in the good in people and I
understand in in one sense I think maybe
me and you I agree well and you know
what the Patriots made their own bed I
mean you know historically they have to
answer these questions from a zero
benefit of the doubt you know D and one
of the one person who was at the NFL
meetings last week came back with this
sentiment I said what was it like there
when the Patriots subject came up and he
said well it wasn't really talked about
too much but I think the majority of us
feel like it was any one of the other 31
teams nobody would have thought anything
of it but it's the Patriots so now
everybody's antennae are oh no you're
absolutely right with Peter King from
NBC Sports great football writer every
Monday morning he pens his column
football morning in America let's talk a
little football now such a jumbled
picture in the NFC Peter you have four
teams that could either be a number one
seed or a number five seed who are in
the postseason right now what what's the
number what's the main team the one team
in the NFC that you look at he say man I
would not want to play them right now
Wow I would say I really want to see New
Orleans tonight and see how they play I
would say still probably San Francisco
and I know that people in Seattle will
scream at that but when the 49ers and
Seahawks played a month ago George
Kittel did not play George tittle right
now is one of the most influential non
quarterbacks playing the sport of
football he he won that game in New
Orleans he did it he did it
and making that play at the end and so I
would say probably San Francisco but I
could also give you a good argument for
the Saints and certainly I mean all
Seattle does is when I I wrote my column
today then think about what Seattle has
done Seattle had five Eastern time zone
games this year every one of which was
played at 10:00 a.m. on their body clock
and they went five and OH
I just think that is one of the most
remarkable accomplishments of this or
any other recent season that's
incredible and that that defense is not
the same Seattle defense that we've seen
in the past but when they have a lead at
halftime they seldom give it up they
they are they are so good at holding on
to a lead or the Seahawks let me flip
this to the AFC Peter I'll give you the
order of teams that I don't want to see
if I'm in the AFC playoff picture right
now you got the Ravens it's kind of the
Ravens and everybody else I feel like
Kansas City has an upward trend
arrow because Patrick mahomes is healthy
a lot of people would want to put the
bills on this list after their win last
night and I just I'm not ready to put
them ahead of New England and I hate
them now break it down to you know it's
most bare sense here but I'm not gonna
trust Josh Allen in the postseason over
Tom Brady even if Tom Brady doesn't have
a single weapon I'm I might be ready to
put them ahead of New England it's been
so long since you mean the Patriots play
a really really good offensive game this
is a fantastic test for the Patriots
Saturday afternoon the Foxborough
because to me they're gonna have to win
by winning the turnover battle
I just don't think their offense is
going to put up more than say 17 points
alone on this Buffalo defense do you
like having three games on Saturday
because I think it's delicious I love it
yeah I love it especially because every
game has a little something to it I
remember doing the schedule story at the
beginning of the year are in
in April sitting there with Howard Katz
and and Mike North and their crew there
and one of the things that they talked
about is really trying to get the late
season games that they were going to put
on nationally it all means something so
they had this this this thing where they
are they were going to choose they were
going to put three of five games on late
in the year on a Saturday which probably
a pain for some fans who make travel
arrangements to go to games but it's
fantastic for the TV fan because that
gives you insurance that you can put two
games on on Sunday that are the least
attractive ones out of those five and
you can have three nationally televised
games on Saturday on NFL Network all of
which should have some little playoff
factor to them they're great games I
mean the first one's going to be the
Texans in the box and you could say
that's the worst of the three but the
Bucs of won four straight Jameis is
looking great you wrote about him in
your column then you have the bills and
the Patriots at 4:30 and then the Rams
and the 49ers at 8:15 Eastern is the
nightcap and that's an absolutely huge
game Peter as a Redskins fan I thought
it was very interesting to see Urban
Meyer and Dan Snyder's box yesterday is
that much ado about nothing considering
he has a couple of his former players on
the team I you know I don't know I don't
know where Ben Meyer I know that some
people who know him well would be very
surprised if he were ever went to the
NFL I ever coached in the NFL because he
just he's not somebody who sits there
and studies the NFL or studies you know
what's what's going on there and I think
the other problem was looking at Urban
Meyer is that he's you know he he has he
doesn't have a long shelf life
everywhere you know he's been obviously
and so and again I have no idea maybe
it's just he's a buddy a Dan Schneider
and they're sitting there watching the
game I don't know but I didn't I
didn't draw from that that that Urban
Meyer is gonna coach Washington no Peter
last question before we let you go the
league meetings last week what was the
most interesting thing to come out of
that for you was it a potential of a 17
game season was it the change in the
drug policy what what because there's so
many things that could be different two
years from now yeah I keep hearing
people around the NFL talk
optimistically about being able to get a
new CBA done a year or so in advance of
the end of the CBA which will be after
next season so you know by you know
after the draft in 2021 is when the CBA
expires I I just simply don't see it dan
I
I mean des Morris Smith if he makes a
deal early is going to have everybody
saying he cave to the owners so unless
they make an incredible demand and say
we want 52% of the growth and the owners
say okay and and end it that way
then I could see the thing ending but I
still think this is going to be a
drawn-out process and it's going to take
at least a year now again I'm not in
there you're not in there we don't know
but I haven't heard many reasons to be
optimistic Eric Winston the NFLPA
president told Dan Kaplan of the
athletic a week or so ago that he looks
at some of these reports about optimism
he said where where is that coming from
he he doesn't see it so anyway we'll see
what happens well I'm curious to see
certainly how that plays out the 17 game
season is a topic that many of discussed
Peter King NBC his football morning in
America column is a must read each and
every Monday Peter thanks for the time
we really appreciate it
you're welcome being all the best to you
you as well for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app